if you are rich and need protection
you're going to come to us to armor your
vehicle we are the largest supplier of
private armored vehicles in the world we
do a low-level type protection which
will provide protection against handgun
type weapon and we also have a higher
level of protection that will provide
protection against ak-47 m16 308 round
type ammunition we have a wide variety
of customers that require armored
vehicles politicians celebrities all the
way to businessmen in West Africa
outside of the US our customers are more
targeted because of the fear of
kidnapping for ransom or even
assassination
this is a Mercedes G wagon this vehicle
most likely is going to West Africa
probably an oil company executive that
needs a protection over there so this
vehicle is in the middle of the process
we use a lightweight material in the
doors we use a ballistic steel
everywhere else on the inside and we
also replace the glass with armored
glass basically it's being rebuilt from
the inside we also add some James Bond
type accessories we can have smoke
coming out of the back of the vehicle it
creates like a smoke screen and if
anybody tries to touch your door handle
it's going to give me an electric shock
this prevents anybody from opening your
vehicle and pulling you out the actual
cost of the armoring materials is quite
high so our profits are usually pretty
small we're doing well because of the
high demand I networking individuals
here in the United States are coming to
us more often because of a perceived
threat against them
the future of this business is really
here in the United States the demand for
armored vehicles is booming